it would be a crime if I didn't bring up
your incredibly lovely and talented wife
Megan Mullally I thought you guys you
guys have become a Hollywood power
couple and you're it's no I've hung out
with you guys you're absolutely a blast
to hang out we're both powerful how did
you meet cuz I don't know this I've
known you for a long time I don't
remember how you met Wigan we met doing
a play at a Theatre Company in Los
Angeles in the year 2000 in the year
2000 called the evidence-room and Megan
was coming off at two years of Will and
Grace 1.0 first time around yeah and I
was living in someone's basement and we
met we met at the first rehearsal and
what it I mean obviously she's very
beautiful she's very talented was there
something particular about her that that
you know made her extra special to you
or attracted you yeah I mean I think
those things sort of made her seem
unattainable or like oh wow that that's
a lady of the fancy ilk that usually
doesn't associate with me with a
basement dweller that's right but we we
were the only two outsiders everybody
else kind of knew each other so we were
off to the side together and her casual
comments to me she just was filthy
immediately
backstage like you know giving me it's
the things she would say in and aside
about my balls just immediately she she
would just go to that go to that you
know from the get-go yeah out of the
gate welcome to Hollywood yeah
so you want to be in showbiz yeah yeah
she which you referred she's still
refers to them as my juicy low-hangers
to which I say wait up wait till I hit
my 60s deer yeah
you